GARY LO: I want people to enjoy the process of finding a new home.
I hope that when they are jealous
When living in a new home
Be able to feel happy
I feel very honored to be involved in this process.
Yes, this is the most important meaning for me.
My name is Gary Lo.
I am the head of Android development at Domain.
We can be in Australia
Buyers, investors, sellers, tenants and real estate agents
Provide a variety of search tools and useful information
We are a large company with more than 500 employees
And launched a variety of products
Our Android team has three developers
We work closely with the design team and the user experience team.
HENRIQUE MARASSI: My name is Henrique.
I am the product manager of Domain.
We spent a very interesting time at Domain.
Our Android app has made great progress in the past few years.
I thought that when I was just starting out with Gary, I realized that the ideal was full and the reality was very skinny.
a lot of navigation problems
User feedback is also very bad
GARY LO: In desperation, we have in-depth training for team members.
And designed to be dedicated to
Android platform application
HENRIQUE MARASSI: I am really lucky to want to come to us now.
Because the company supported us very much at the time.
And invest a lot of money to let us develop the best Android apps.
GARY LO: After designing a very standard framework
We really started to make the most of it.
All the tools Google and Android offer
We hope that users can understand
The environment around the property
So introduced Google Maps
We hope that users will receive notifications in a timely manner
And GCM's push function helps us achieve this.
We want users to be able to explore the surrounding companies while walking around the street.
So we used the geofencing function
Play with Play
We can easily create these experiences for our users.
HENRIQUE MARASSI: 2014 is a very important year for us
Because we released a lot of powerful features such as finger search
This feature is integrated with Google Now and designed with Material Design
GARY LO: Material Design can provide a very useful guide
It will guide us how to design an application
Help us create an immersive experience for our users
User response is very intense
Our monthly downloads have increased by 44%
Domain applications are also included
Top 5 Australian lifestyle apps
Hear the real user and praise the app.
And we are very pleased and honored how this app helps them find new homes.
Our rating on the Play Store
Also jumped from 2.8 stars to 4.1 stars
HENRIQUE MARASSI: We will work harder in the future
Continuously develop and improve this app
Let users in the process of buying a house
Can really enjoy its convenience
This year is indeed a bumper year for us.
We can’t wait to see it.
What surprise will the Android platform bring to us next?